l'équipe de france de retour au
vélodrome de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
les pistards tricolore pas encore au
complet peuvent de nouveau s'entraîner
depuis ce jeudi 18 juin sur la piste
les premiers coups de pédales après
trois mois d'arrêt je suis super
contente franchement ça fait vraiment
plaisir de retrouver tout le groupe
les coéquipiers les coach le staff ça
fait vraiment du bien ça faisait bizarre
parce que ça faisait longtemps qu'on
n'avait pas roulé sur la piste de rouler
sur en eau en haut avec l'inclinaison ça
fait un peu pas peur mais on appréhende
un peu la première fois même si ça se
passe toujours très bien
le premier virage ça fait un peu bizarre
mais au bout de deux efforts c'est comme
si on n'était jamais parti pour
reprendre en toute sécurité un protocole
strict anticopie de 19 a été mise en
place dans la structure
on a le port du masque bon là on l'a pas
parce qu'on est sur notre vélo mais les
entraîneurs ont les masques on quand on
arrive quand on entre dans le vélodrome
c'est désinfection des mains on a le
port du masque pour voyager entre les
vestiaires les salles de tout ça on a
chacun notre table chacun notre
emplacement qu'on change pas et voilà
après on nettoie chaque fois quand on
arrive quand on repart les pistards de
l'équipe de france attendent maintenant
une clarification sur le calendrier des
compétitions internationales des
sportifs pourrait ne pas courir avant la
mi octobre date des prochains
championnats d'europe sur piste qui
devrait être organisé en bulgarie